in film as in life the briefest moments
can leave the most lasting impressions
these films come from different parts of
the world are told in different
languages and even though each of them
is under 40 minutes long they stay with
us long act after we watch here are the
nominees for Best live action short film
aya Oded boo noon and McHale brazos
Boogaloo and Graham Michael Lennox and
Ronan Blaine butter lamp lamp
aboard a yacht hue and Julianne fair a
par Verna Tarun Hamza V and Stefan
Eichenberg
the phone call Matt Kirkby and James
Lucas and the Oscar goes to the phone
call
first Oscar format Kirby and James Lucas
rightly crikey I write these are big
buggers these are heavier
we're only little and they're heavy to
us so I'm particularly happy because
this now means I can get a free donut at
my local bakery the punch Street bakery
they do fantastic doughnuts yes we stick
to the script
yes stage the script thank you to the
Academy you've been brilliant 22 seconds
to go
thanks to my crew who all give their
time for free short films are made not
with money they're made with tenacity
and lots of favors impossible to do it
without them thank you to sally hawkins
who donated her incredible talents to us
for nothing this is for you and thank
you to the Academy thanks Academy more
importantly we'd like to divide it up
and we'd like to add the music we'd like
to thank all the volunteers around the
world in crisis centers who give their
time for nothing including our mums
including our mums
James's mother my mum volunteer for
nothing friends and family back home
Gary who should have been here and most
of all around her I love you